[Music]
today we cancel kelly karan who is a
popular personality on the platform
twitch where people usually go to watch
other people play video games but
apparently some twitch streamers will um
simply go about their mundane everyday
lives and broadcast all of it and fans
will sit and watch it's a bit like the
truman show except in this case the
stars of the show are aware that they're
on camera and also a lot of time they
have none of the charm or personality of
jim carrey's character in that film and
that brings us to streamer kelly who was
live streaming
while cooking a few days ago
and there's nothing immediately strange
about watching somebody cook i've been
known to enjoy a cooking show or two in
my time but usually you watch somebody
cook because they're a master chef and
you're watching in order to learn their
techniques
or else they're an amateur chef and
you're watching to see gordon ramsay
verbally abuse them for overcooking the
salmon or whatever what i don't quite
understand is watching someone cook
alone in their kitchen
when they apparently aren't even
familiar with the rudimentary basics of
cooking
now i'm speaking somewhat rhetorically
here i i do actually understand why
people sit and watch live streams where
the star of the show has nothing
interesting to say and isn't doing
anything worth watching it's the same
thing that drives the screen addiction
that most people in this country suffer
from which is loneliness despair
lack of meaning in life people turn to
the internet for companionship having
given up on real physical relationships
and on physical existence in general but
that's a topic for another time the
point today is this particular twitch
streamer kelly karan who um
was broadcasting live
while cooking attempting to cook rather
a steak
and then things went sideways in a hurry
let's just watch this as this unfolds
here
so she's got the it's it's smoking all
over the place she's got the steak
probably way overcooked
she doesn't turn the burner off
now there's the fire
whipping the pan around the room spread
the fire everywhere
i don't know what to do guys i don't
know what to do turn the stove off first
of all turn the stove off the stove's
still on help
help help help
now she's just shouting at them
out the door
turn the stove off first thing you do
yeah that's frustrating
especially as a dad
you know
that that's that's tough to watch
okay
so she almost burned down her house as
it happens
apparently the fire department showed up
in time and that she escaped without any
major property damage or personal injury
thank god but it could have been much
worse seeing as how she did literally
everything wrong as soon as the
overheated pan she was using to vaporize
that poor steak erupted into flames so
let's go through the missteps one by one
okay i think this will be very helpful
in fact i might save some lives right
here today and that will show so first
she blows on the flame which of course
only makes the problem worse
it's like when you're starting a
campfire and you want to get it going
and you've got the the embers and so you
start blowing on it because you want to
make the fire get bigger
that's why you don't do that with a
kitchen fire blowing only puts out a
fire when the fire is contained on the
wick of a birthday candle
if the flame is much bigger than that
you fuel the fire by giving it more air
so
then she whips the pan around which by
the way is giving it more air okay
because she's whipping it around and she
puts it in her sink where she attempts
and thankfully fails to pour water on it
because if she had succeeded in dousing
her grease fire with water
she would have caused a massive fireball
to erupt out of her sink and likely set
her cabinets aflame
and also probably her hair and
everything else
um and then she whips the pan back
around
spraying hot flaming oil all over the
kitchen like some kind of fiery
sprinkler and sets it back on the stove
without turning the burner off
then she leaves the flame
and the the stove that's still on and
just starts randomly shouting help out
her front door
it's a master class and what not to do
when you have a grease fire in your
kitchen so here's what you should do for
the record
first
remove the pan from its heat source okay
that's the first thing you do
turn off the heat source
your next step is to smother the flame
don't blow on it don't dump water on it
don't dump gasoline or lighter fluid
smother it if the fire's small enough
you could probably take care of the
problem by just putting the lid on the
pan which originally she probably could
have done it before she blew on it she
probably just put the lid on it and that
would have been good enough
it's a bigger fire than you'll need to
smother it by dumping either baking soda
or salt on it just make sure it's baking
soda not baking powder or else you'll be
in for an unfortunate surprise
if you don't have either of those things
handy or if the fire's already too large
to contain that way then use your fire
extinguisher and if you don't have a
fire extinguisher then hopefully you
have a fire blanket if you don't have a
fire blanket and you can't smother with
a lid and you don't have baking soda or
salt or the fire's too big by this point
to put it out that way then just toss
yourself into the fire as penance for
being so woefully unprepared
now actually your last resort in that
situation is to get out of the house
and call 911.
so you didn't think you'd get fire
safety tips on the matt wall show today
but that's where the conversation took
us
and all this leads me to a deeper point
that i think needs to be made here
the comedy of errors that we just
witnessed is a very small microcosm of a
much bigger problem
afflicting our society a huge number of
americans do not possess even the most
basic life skills
like how to put out a kitchen fire
how to cook in the first place so that
you hopefully you don't have fires
um food safety
first aid housekeeping money management
budgeting how to do your taxes how to
change a tire car repair home repair the
list goes on
all of us are deficient in almost all of
us are deficient in some of those areas
many of us are deficient in all of them
and the reason in large part is that
these sorts of things are not being
taught in schools anymore
now obviously parents should be training
their children in these skills
but 50 million kids in this country
spend most of their waking hours through
most of their formative years in school
buildings and that would be in theory
the perfect place to impart a lot of
this kind of knowledge
and there was a time when lots of these
things were covered in school
they even had a whole subject home
economics it was called and they were
that subject was devoted to everyday
life skills like these
but those courses started falling by the
wayside in part because it was
considered two retrograde and unfeminist
to teach kids especially girls how to
cook and clean
and also in part because public school
curriculum started to revolve more and
more around standardized testing and
college readiness
like the focus now is to make kids ready
for college
not for life
and in part because the schools needed
to make room in the day to teach about
lgbt pride and crt and other forms of
insidious nonsense
the end result is that kids whittle away
hundreds of hours in these alleged
educational facilities and come away
from it with almost no practical or
useful knowledge or skills at all
next you know they're live streaming
while burning down their kitchen
you teach these skills
in school
and again would be great if parents
taught it
but it's also a self-perpetuating
problem because the parents we have a
whole generation of parents who don't
know these skills either because they
didn't learn them
teach the skills in in in school isn't
that an interesting concept
to actually
give
kids
useful knowledge that will make their
lives better and easier
make them more self-sufficient
who would have thought
and that's why on second thought uh
maybe i'm not going to cancel kelly
quran
instead i think it's our utterly useless
education system that must be once again
today
cancelled listen hit that subscribe
button right now do it right now i thank
you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated